[Music]
well we're here today with a legend of
the comic book space about to be a
record-breaking comic book space love it
we got to talk about spawn 300 and then
301 rice you the number one
longest-running creator-owned book in
history in history around the globe ever
like you from the dawn of man to today
right so feel that look at I knew this
day was gonna come and so I remember
asking Eric Stephenson publisher an
image she died just make the the big
book not three hundred cuz that ties the
record what if I just make the triple
size issue 301 cuz that's the record
setter right yeah he'd like set the
record go that's why you should be
buying this book it's a record setter
and people would be curious going why
301 and then you'd have to sort of
educate them but we eventually after
conversation just said I the buyers and
the retailers are so used to these
interviewing these anniversary number
one hundred two hundred three hundred
whatever that it's I get if you don't
get the message across it might confuse
them a little bit but I did it in a
two-part there's a cliffhanger at the
end of three hundred that goes into 301
so that basically to me they should be
buying both of those are the same right
but to me that the the story that I'm
trying to get out a little bit isn't
isn't about spawn isn't isn't about me
then about image it's about these
stories that I've read my whole life
were all of a sudden a lot of them come
in the business section that you just
sort of hear about somebody who railed
against the system who railed against
the Giants and they lived to tell about
it
right and they and they had they had
enough success that they got to
basically live their own life right and
so that's to me out of out of anything I
want anybody to walk away with it's just
that because if you get that piece then
it doesn't matter to me that you can
draw a writer color a comic book that's
irrelevant it that's just a the product
that I'm pushing
it's called comic book what should be
sort of more of I'm hope
a bit of an inspiration is you're
looking at a human being that went
against big companies both in the toy
industry and in the comic book and did
something 25 27 30 years ago and 30
years later is still there doing it and
had to make very few compromises along
the way
I'm not saying everything I did was
right I'm not I'm not saying we're not
talking about right and wrong I'm just
saying that if you have an idea and you
have an inspiration you want to peddle
something and say everybody's telling
you no because the system will always
tell you no because they don't want
competition right nobody's ever said hey
you've got a product that will compete
against me oh here let me get out of
your way no no no they will they will
put barricades up there but if you fight
every day for it you can be 30 years
later still doing it and one number 300
27 years after the release of spawn 1 is
gonna be the number one selling book in
the country easily so ok
it's not like it's it's down there it's
gonna pop again going we're still
relevant right so it's doable it's
doable and Image Comics now which was a
force of nature caused an entire shift
in the comics space and continues to
with all these Eisner noms yeah you guys
aren't just like the the comic property
that everyone wants to work for you're
also winning the awards that everyone
seeks after because you rebelled against
the cause and because you said no to the
man yeah and and all that was a
foundation of gathering the best of the
best and making a team that works for
the people well guys I mean getting the
best the best is you know that's awesome
yeah but just getting good creative
talented people who who knows it may be
diamonds in a rough right now that may
be the next set of the next generation
superstars yeah I mean you got to start
them someplace you feel like that's why
image is so successful still it's
finding the people that are worked the
hardest that'll make the big choices
well yeah
image is an interesting company cuz we
don't own anything so we can't be the
one thing we can't do is tell people to
meet their deadlines right it's the one
frustrating part we give you so much
freedom
you can even basically fail on your own
merits if you choose to do so right I
wouldn't be my choice but you go ahead
and do it but we weren't an opportunity
for people who want to basically come in
either the
worked in the systems Marvel DC or
whoever and then want to try their own
hand at doing something creative or
people who will never get into those
companies nor do they even have any
aspirations to because their books
aren't superhero stories right there I
mean you know our books we do close to
70 books a month they're very eclectic
right we have a wide range of books and
some of them are very eclectic and those
people aren't trying to tell stories so
that it will then get them a job on
Superman or Batman right they're just
telling the sort of super personal story
and I go up on stage and I'm gonna do it
again on Saturday and I'm gonna know and
I'm gonna give them the Dada speech at
hallelujah speech of that I think today
is the best day to be doing independent
comic books and and although I used to
say you can you if you're as long as
you're well number 140 and the other 139
or Marvel and DC you're gonna be number
one so let me deal with the reality of
what I just said because it's becoming
truer every month last month and I'm
talking about if you want to do comic
books and you can make you know a decent
money but if you're looking to sort of
see if you're gonna you know aspire to
things that are outside of just comic
books if you have that sort of whim of
the hundred top 100 books 95 of them
were either a Marvel DC okay so Warner
Brothers doesn't share and Disney's not
gonna be sharing so if you're if your
name isn't Disney or Warner Brothers
then and you're either ABC NBC CBS a
streaming a you know company or some
Internet company or cable or the
thousand producers that sit in that that
city called Hollywood who are all
looking for content and they say we've
got to come up with some comic books out
of the top 100 ideas or at least sales
yeah 95 of them are off limits you got
to have to redact them so there's only 5
left ok so let's talk about last month
there was only five left yeah right and
the top 50 is only two ones called
walking dead sold right the other ones
spawn not for sale yeah the next one
then is saga already sold yep and then
there's one that was Archie owned by
Warner Brothers and there's another one
that has already been optioned so I am
telling you of the
top 100 books zero is for sale yeah if
you're if you're anybody other than
Warner Brothers and and Disney zero okay
I started I started going through it the
first book that to my and I don't even
know if it's true I should throw on the
credit that I go I don't know they
actually have a deal with anybody is a
hundred and eight and then the next one
is a hundred and twenty two so so I go
if you're a hundred and twenty-two
you're the second you're the second
there's a second best available property
to dozens and dozens and dozens of
corporations and thousands potentially
producers right so this joke that I used
to make go you'll be 140 is now
completely true now that your goal
should be if you want to do an
independent comic book if you want to do
an independent comic book your goal
should be can I get to 108 because if
you get two hundred days you're gonna be
gold main goal if you're anywhere
between 108 and 200 you're still gonna
be gold it's like batting 300 like you
hit one out of three altogether it's
good handling paper girls you guys just
got adapted like that's moved at Amazon
and saga is selling like crazy and and
what image is done is built a foundation
for creatives to be creative right and
that's what I love about it and 300 is
happening for you because of that 27
years ago 27 years making it happen fry
for a long time I was talking to his
funny cuz I was talking to Robert
Kirkman the other day you know cuz you
know he recently cancelled the Walker
brilliant right brilliantly right and
again I'm going why don't you go to 200
you go Todd why are you what these big
round numbers
anyways we're having this conversation
with them but he but he's gone 193 he
goes for me to even think about 300
where you're going he goes Todd I have
to add 10 more years she's not off
that's about 10 more years yeah he goes
up all my brains I gotta go hit more
you're like he goes I've told my story
I'm good and and I want to do it and
it's time for me to move on and do
whatever else right so I I go the the
the successes of image has always been
for me that you the creative person
get to do whatever you want with the
story with the art how long you want it
to be you want to do it for 10 years you
want to do for 10 minutes you want to
make toys out of it you don't you want
somebody that you want to sell it to
Hollywood make a video game you don't
you think that that's selling out all of
that is on you and and every time the
creator on their own book gets to make
the decision personally that's the
victory tally for me not that they got
the deal not that it went and made a lot
of money for them on TV or just that
they were able to say the yeses in the
nose themselves check check check check
check every single time
yeah that's about it yeah sure right now
speaking of being rebellious with art I
am talking another important three
hundred we talked before about venom
being a subject of like not wanting to
draw a certain costume and bring a
costume into the the way with 300 you
invented venom basically out of wanting
to draw spider-man in his proper form
like the red and blue Kosh with the
right besides your classic the classic
right so the venom was basically made
out of spite and that's also kind of
what image represents like we call it a
happy accident right
you know I guess you know most you will
look at 300 amazing spider-man 300 and
say oh my god 300 that's the that's the
origin of venom issue
I call it can we get rid of that damn
black costume so we can get back to the
red and blue Spidey cause issue we knew
that we were onto something when every
time we brought that character back
people seem to respond to him yeah oh my
god hey you know what because the thing
that was interesting back then was there
were there wasn't this new era you were
getting like the new x-men the new
uncanny x-men and you were getting you
know some you know Deadpool will end up
coming in and X Factor's and some other
characters came on so the superheroes
were there was like this new generation
coming but but what struck me was there
wasn't a new generation of villains
right because I go all the good ones are
still Doc Ock and Doctor Doom and
Magneto and all you know all the doc the
doctor names from the 60s that you go
weren't worth what's the equivalent of
those now
and so in an accidental way venom
started sort of coming in and asserting
himself over time of being sort of a
villain on a high scale that people
started to recognize right I wish there
was 20 more of them that not venoms but
like these characters that were came out
from the 90s and even in in in the 2000s
that were comparable to the doc dooms
and then and you know the red skulls and
those kinds of ones that are just these
vicious you know the Joker's and the
Riddler's like who's the modern-day
version of those yeah so when you
invented venom it was it was you wanting
to draw the red in blue costume which I
loved because now it's become one of the
biggest characters in the world out of a
billion dollar happy accident Tony Tony
you're welcome
so this billion dollar happy accident
and also I love that it appeared in
$2.99 and that's where 300 the number of
people think of it now at spawn 301 is
actually the number so you actually
dance around these anniversary numbers
it's not the good thought yeah so let's
talk about 301 for a minute yeah what
sort of interesting odd and maybe just
me is that the record that I'm going to
tie at 300 is a book that was black and
white independent book her own book
called Cerebus the day sim dead yes Dave
sim also quite proudly I could say it
was a Canadian I'm a Canadian it's a bit
of a head-scratcher to me that the world
record was held by a Canadian it's gonna
now be broke by another Canadian I'm
wondering about the other 122 countries
as to like what's happening to the work
ethic you're slacking America and all
all right so somebody step up and do 400
issues come on let's go Deadpool also
Canadian I'm calling you all out America
the difference is though he you I don't
know if you remember Dave sim said he's
gonna do 300 and quit
yeah and true to his word he did it
right so now to me it's just now gonna
be more Cal Ripken junior you know game
played streak once he got past Lou
Gehrig's record he just kept playing
right and so he didn't just beat it by
one game he kept going so end in sight
every issue becomes the new record right
so I just got so whoever thinks they're
gonna get to 300 I go 300 that was so 15
years ago right so
I don't know we'll see I like I said it
there it really is a very proud moment
for me to just say that I started this
and 2530 years later I'm still driving
it right that's it
good better and different we can have
that conversation and debate another day
right but but it's still the same human
being doing it
thirty years later it's doable right
it's doable
now with the book that you're setting
records a little bit every month going
forward is there anything you want to do
at the character you feel like you
couldn't do before do you feel like it's
just as like a viable now as it was ever
or more so yeah he yeah there's a few
surprises who's gonna happen in 300 301
okay right some some some visual hits
some some power hits they're gonna be
there and then you know I'm gonna try
and see if I can't entice a few
unexpected surprising artists to come on
board maybe do a story arc here they're
right I mean you know what look at it's
incumbent upon us as a creative people
especially if you're gonna do something
with longevity and spawn obviously as
one of the books got longevity so you're
gonna have peaks and valleys of story of
art of sales of all of it right because
it just absence lows right Superman
Batman spider-man gone through all the
same sort of peaks and valleys
so it's uncommon upon us the creative
people and for me because I'm the owner
of the the the character so to to make
it to give a reason for the consumer the
customers to buy it and the retailer
right I can't just say hey I've been
here this long you should be basically
backing me up I have to basically
inspire them to basically want it so
I've been making a gallant effort the
last you know a couple years especially
last year to get people back on board to
at least at least sample spawn again
because it may be different than what
you thought you remembered it being and
then give them reasons to keep coming
back right so they'll go oh my gosh this
this is sort of a little bit different
or there's some cool stuff er I didn't
know I didn't know I didn't remember and
for the retailers who every month and I
and I understand you know that life they
get that thick book that's got 10,000
items in it called the diamond preview
and
it's easy to get into autopilot because
it's just it's you you can't pay
attention to everything in there so so
what happens is easy for them say hey I
order 10 copies of that book 10 copies
10 copies 10 copies no matter what's
happening but better than different
they'll order the 10 and so it's up to
me to say I think you should be ordering
15 right so here's why here's the story
here's the artist here's the writer
here's what's happening with the
character all of it right and give them
a reason to go oh and jolt them out of
it and say oh oh yeah it's fun we used
to buy more of that maybe we'll give it
a bigger sample and and you know I know
even having that conversation with the
retailers recently the retailer summit
that from that conversation I had on the
stage the very next issue went up 50%
not not 5% 50% so so glad handing and
being being aware of the retailers and
the consumers at all times not not just
sort of assuming they owe you something
is beneficial he's also a very public
figure because of the the movie and the
TV show and he's been in the limelight
for a long time so toys toys set the
precedent for the 90s toys and your guys
are doing another run with McFarlane
Toys
to celebrate this now bringing it back
in the public eye is there any movement
on the Blum House thing or is that still
on the same time right now I'm currently
rewriting it because you know one of the
differences with the movie is that and
all my other businesses I put my own
money in so that that rebel spirit can
be there
the moment you start asking people for
the money you know they rightly so get
I'll they get a lot of they get a lot of
food at the table and they and they get
to say yes and no and they're not just
gonna say hey Todd here's a bunch of
money you spend any way you see fit I
wouldn't do it myself
alright so I get it so I'm just trying
to maneuver through that system I'm not
the only guy that's ever tried to get
something made in Hollywood that took a
little bit longer than we would have
liked right
I'm anxious you know I know Jason always
going taught it happened when it happens
right don't worry about it because he's
been through it dozens of time so but
right now I just want to focus on
getting the 300 301 so that so that I
can remind Hollywood again that you're
missing out on the the biggest
longest-running creator-owned history I
think you should probably make this a no
by the way last time it opened up to 40
million or to 20 million and it would be
40 million in today's dollars
so you're missing you're missing one and
we'll get it but patience patience and
just be part of it I love the cast and I
love that starting in October you are
going to be every month the
record-setting book of all time starting
at 301 in to 302 into 303 into forever
I'm so excited congratulations can we
fit appreciate absolutely thanks Todd
yeah